tali che cos'è il massimo tutti a questo
video sono qua vj oggi siamo su allora
robe ma rob e proprio insieme di giochi
proprio che non ha senso di esistere c'è
adesso ve lo faccio vedere sono infatti
da un cristiano che si chiama robert
young voglio chiamarmi
non posso scrivere il mio nome posso
solo generarli a caso sexy tali walker
va bene sexy questo va molto bene che
gioco e so che è strano ma non so perché
ci sono delle fottute cos chi cazzo sei
stanno mandando dei messaggi come se sì
però farsi selfin nel cesso con lo sco
il con lo spazzolone proprio bello pieno
di merda posso diventare nero adesso il
mio pene un quello di un mandingo ai
filtri ci sono i video i filtri di st ma
come la russa no mamma sono occupato sto
facendo cose posso fare le foto
certo ovviamente ti mando questa pole
vieni della mando ho trovato questa
questa barra qui e che serve a una cosa
che non posso farvi vedere però vela
simbolo voi dovete capire a cosa serve
cucco le censure che ha capito
[Musica]
si vabbè lasciamo perdere anni 90 e
accordo ragazzi siamo su un altro video
che c'è l'italiano il suono importante
usa si sono sotto la doccia ragazzi è
sempre dallo strazio di prima sto gioco
e quindi non voglio pensare sì ma perché
siamo in doccia perché non voglio vedere
queste cose
per cortesia due mi amò dall'altra parte
perché ogni caso di gioco che ha fatto
sto cristiano
[Musica]
perché fai la doccia con gli occhiali
three cristo cina è occupato è occupato
dove ne frega un cazzo di vederti
entrati fai la doccia
no no no no tua madre lo fanno lo faccio
io non lo tocco neanche se mi pagano
miliardi mi rifiuto di fare questa comun
perché a parte il fatto che io la mano
più sexy che abbia mai visto in tutta la
mia vita
credo che sia il gioco più gay che io
abbia mai fatto hai finito posso finirla
di inviarti la spalla perché è una cosa
che fa
ok
quanto mi piace fai quello che minchia
ti pare ma non far cadere la saponetta
per terra ti prego non ti girare non
voglio vederti fa non ti guardo neanche
se no no no no ma stai scherzando non ti
toccherò ai peli pubici che hai sul
petto zio o mio dio
poi penso di ragazzi sto per vomitare ho
appena appurato che il creatore di sti
giochi è un maniaco
devo devo bcp hai un braccio nel braccio
gennaio un braccio
vabbè ma è ascoltato ai dei bicipiti che
ski giuro ma te lo giuro sono
formidabili sei bellissimo ma come cazzo
se la il braccio fra terra e gente che
se morbido certo voglio voglio uscire
voglio uscire da questo gioco si può
uscire subito grazie ragazzi siamo
settimi plenty che sarebbero fare quindi
adesso
mettiti sulle fottute ginocchia no no no
no no no no no no no ha chisto sculaccia
no pensavo fosse per niente falso
allarme lo sto sculaccia ndaw ragazzi
non sto solo sculacciato tranquillo io
lo vedo che rosso lo vedo è però è che
dobbiamo fare è morto ma perché lo devo
consolare dopo quello che è successo non
volevo schiacciarti io volevo
semplicemente mostrarti come come si fa
il peggio un acchiappa prendere è finito
vi rendete conto che cazzo di giochi fa
noto partner è ricoverato per gli abusi
che ha subito io accendi suono si sia
acceso acceso tranquillo io posso
girarla che bello che sono stick shift
un gioco autoerotico
perché a cena
[__] ragazzi no non mi rifiuto
visto rifiutare mai capito che cazzo fai
le sedie al guidiamo la questo non è un
gioco auto è semplicemente un gioco con
le mario non guarderò mai più il cambio
della macchina nello se adesso vi deve
essere condizionato dai videogiochi mi
hanno condizionato il cambio della
macchina adesso non potrò più guardarlo
come prima cazzo eccolo lì perfetto mai
che la nonna ti aspetta con le
tagliatelle vai se metti la quarta se le
senti le tagliatelle che sono più vicine
se vai vai in autostrada e 500 allora
per arrivare prima se si guarda che
arrivi se c'è anche la sesta marcia
oh mio dio mio dio mio dio sexta come
sommessa siamo arrivati alla nonna
siamo arrivati alla nonna o mio dio sono
stanchissimo
ci spero che mia madre cosa fa siamo
arrivati ragazzi after after drive
spero vivamente che mia madre non mi
abbia sentito di la ciao ragazzi con
l'ultimo video game senta lei dietro
nella natura e davanti veglia abbastanza
bene seta tra colori prima che si faceva
la doccia che cazzo ti stai facendo alle
mutande ok succulente un gioco profondo
di robert young robert young ma che
cazzo di problemi ai nel cervello sa
perché ma per ma che cazzo di cosa far
velo dietro a cosa fai
l'altro quasi finito il gelato regali
tra dopo tutto sto casino
non lo so se lo sa cosa fa ma cosa fa ma
cos'è e cosa fa
addio si e small e colato tutto a caso
c'è sismo letta è finito così perché ora
ragazzi con
vedevo l'ora di concludere giuro ma poi
no poi perché credo che da adesso in
avanti io possa essere più lo stesso c'è
sta salendo
lo sbocco e lasciate un mi piace perché
questo video è bello allora ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio è stato
bellissimo cazzo gli aspetti lo rifaccio
robe robert young robert young e tu che
crei questi videogiochi
hai mai pensato di farsi vedere ma non
da uno psicologo proprio da tutti quanti
i fatti un bel giro di cristiani e crei
chiedi qual è il tuo problema chiedi io
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
sei tu se vi è piaciuta solamente un
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
cosa divi nottata nella descrizione sono
saliti discrete noi ci vediamo quasi un
vino e ragazzi e speriamo di trovare di
meglio
preghiamo bella ragazza